hola de nuevo quiero disculparme por
anticipado porque ahorita estoy en un
cuarto de hotel pues porque mi novia
vino a un congreso de estadística y
estoy usando mi laptop con hardware que
no es el mejor del mundo entonces a lo
mejor no se vea tan padre como se ve
usualmente pero vamos a seguir
intentando esto de aprender entonces
vamos a empezar como casi todos los
vídeos pero ahora con un pequeño cambio
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es empezar
con 300 de capital y solo 100 de esos
van a ser para construir el banco para
hacer mi edificio entonces esto de aquí
es para mi bóveda
es la estructura física dónde está el
dinero entonces todavía me sobran 200
verdad le metí 300 de capital así que
todavía me quedan 200 piezas de oro que
voy a meter en mi bóveda para que la
gente vea cómo es eso de guardar dinero
entonces mi capital es 300 piezas de oro
más 300 piezas de
muy bien ahí serían las inversiones
iniciales
entonces empezamos a aceptar depósitos
de ciertos aldeanos no sé ahorita llega
el aldeano a y quiere depositar algo de
su dinero depositar 100 piezas de oro
100 piezas de oro esto de ahí es oro y
luego bueno soya y es un activo pero
tiene un pasivo correspondiente el
pasivo correspondiente va a ser pues no
sé digamos que es una cuenta de cheques
entonces vamos a poner que es la cuenta
de el aldeano a él puede escribir
cheques pagar cosas ya vimos cómo
funciona esta obra lo puede utilizar
este como dinero para hacer ciertos
pagos luego viene la persona ve tiene un
poquito más de dinero y deposita
doscientas piezas de oro 200 piezas de
oro la persona ve necesita un poco más
de liquidez entonces pide la mitad en
cuenta de cheques y la mitad en efectivo
va en notas bancarias entonces esto de
acá sería la cuenta de cheques
de ahí ve puede escribir cheques y la
otra parte de la quiere en efectivo
en notas bancarias
entonces estoy acá sería el pasivo de
notas bancarias pendientes sería 100 y
abajo también es 100 aquí también es 100
muy bien entonces pues voy a expedir
algunas notas bancarias para estos 100 y
digamos que voy a expedir cinco notas de
cada una tiene que ser de veinte verdad
entonces 20 20 20 20 ahí en medio tiene
la foto del apuesto fundador del banco y
abajo dice el banco de sal muy bien
entonces se los doy ave y puede
utilizarlo para pagar cosas y lo que sea
bueno puede comprar su superior con lo
que sea no sé entonces usa esto porque
cualquier persona que tenga de estas
notas puede venir al banco y pedir
piezas de oro por eso funciona como algo
que tiene valor verdad
bueno o sea no sabemos que nos tenga
quien los tenga puede venir y pagar eso
lo hicimos en el vídeo pasado vimos cómo
se pueden hacer algunas transacciones
entre a&b verdad pueden hacer algunos
cambios en sus cuentas de cheques o
pagarse con notas bancarias no importa
vamos a ver qué sucede cuando empezamos
a prestar un poco de dinero entonces
vamos a suponer que alguien tiene un
proyecto que necesite 300 piezas de oro
va antes sacábamos las mil piezas de oro
de la bóveda así se las dábamos en bruto
al al emprendedor y con eso él le pagaba
a sus trabajadores ya con el pago
construían el canal y crecía la economía
pero ahora tenían dinero que volvían a
depositar y sellamos un cierto proceso
lo que queremos hacer ahorita es
intentar hacer esto sin que el oro salga
de las bóvedas porque porque no queremos
que salga pues número uno por seguridad
todos porque el oro no es muy práctico
para hacer transacciones
esto que ya platicamos de que es pesado
de que es difícil de fraccionar
no sé o sea hay riesgos de seguridad y
es impráctico entonces vamos a intentar
hacerlo sin oro como ya hacemos pues
llega el emprendedor y esta ave se un
emprendedor sé qué quiere hacer pues
otra vez esto del canal de irrigación y
para esto necesita 300 piezas de oro va
entonces esto entra como un activo
entran 300 piezas de oro entran como un
activo porque es un préstamo es un
préstamo que yo espero que me paguen
después va entonces en vez de tomar el
oro de las bóvedas y prestarse lo hace
lo que voy a hacer es abrirle una cuenta
de cheques hace para que pueda realizar
pagos mal entonces le voy a abrir una
cuenta de cheques al emprendedor si a lo
mejor que era un poquito de efectivo
mejor vamos a pensar que quiere un
poquito de efectivo vamos a pensar que
sólo quiere 100 que quiere si en este en
su cuenta de cheques y luego los otros
200 vamos a poner 200 los ponemos en
notas bancarias pendientes y ex pedimos
20 billetes 20 notas bancarias
y es
ahí tenemos un montón de papelitos que
imprimí y que son super seguros 10 10 y
pues el puede usar esto para pagarle a
sus obreros verdad y sus obreros palombo
no quieren papelitos quieren oro vienen
al banco y ya con el papelito yo se los
intercambio por oro vamos a tomar un
segundo emprendedor otro emprendedor que
quiere hacer una fábrica y me está
pidiendo pues no se me va a pedir 100
piezas de oro algo de este tamaño
entonces otra vez es un activo es un
préstamo de 100 piezas de oro para d
otra vez le hacemos una cuenta de
cheques pues aquí le ponemos esta es la
cuenta de cheques para ve y es de 100 y
creo que ya sé qué estás pensando parece
ser que estoy haciendo dinero de la nada
parecería que podría seguir
incrementando a ambos lados de mi hoja
de balance tanto como quiera conforme
hago préstamos pero si lo piensas
tantito será muy parecido cuando cuando
lo hacíamos con oro simplemente teníamos
que esperar a que el oro regresara
entonces bueno especialmente aquí
estamos guardando el oro y utilizando
cuentas de cheques y emitiendo ciertas
notas bancarias verdad bueno entonces
supongamos que el emprendedor de quiere
hacer su fábrica y que es la persona
encargada de hacer fábricas va entonces
cómo es que se da la transacción aquí
está de aquí está
la persona de le va a escribir a un
cheque lo que sea que sea un cheque va a
escribir toda la información no se lo
firma de es una fábrica escribió por acá
que son 100 escribe alguna otra cosa lo
que está que es un cheque vaya es un
papel que se pueda autenticar para que
cuando lo lleve al banco el banco puede
estar seguro de que de lo escribió y
pueda hacer la transferencia de fondos
entonces lo que pasa es que al edad de
su fábrica la construye ok entonces a
cambio a recibe este papelito que es una
orden una orden de de para el banco para
que transfiera parte de sus fondos a la
cuenta de a el banco hace este cambio
que lo voy a poner así con el color de a
entonces todo esto de aquí todas estas
100 piezas son ahora de a ahora observa
que una vez más hicimos transacciones
sin necesidad de sacar oro de las
bóvedas seguro y práctico
la pregunta natural es qué tanto puedes
seguir este proceso será que un banco
puede seguir así indefinidamente
haciendo préstamos y abriendo cuentas de
cheques o también será que el banco
puede
las notas bancarias que sea y estas
notas tienen intereses ok
bueno la respuesta es que no digo el
banco podría seguir pues inventándose
cuentas y lo que sea pero tiene que
cumplir con ciertos requisitos con
ciertas regulaciones de reservas que su
dinero esté bien respaldado estos
requisitos de reserva nos dicen que
tanto puede prestar un banco en
comparación con las reservas que tenga
en este caso sería en reservas de oro
aunque sabes que creo que hay una mejor
definición es que tantas cuentas de
cheques y que tantas notas bancarias
puede emitir con respecto a sus reservas
pero bueno el punto de este vídeo fue
ver cómo podemos realizar préstamos sin
que el oro salga de las bóvedas en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a hablar más
acerca de estas regulaciones de reservas
vamos a platicar que son y por qué son
importantes viendo algunos casos
extremos nos vemos